hello everyone we said we were gonna
show on another game from around eight
of the 2019 singles Cup so here it is
it's the only Pony versus LaVon Oregon
and it's quite an interesting game it's
a it's a quiet game but also not so
without further ado let's just enjoy the
game young opens with the white pieces
and he plays efore with E 5 by 11 Knight
to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4 with
Knight to f6 from lemon the two Knights
defense and now d3 we're not gonna be
seeing any Knight to g5 action today
unfortunately Bishop to c5 and now comes
castles with d6 and c3 are preparing to
expand on the Queen side and also
preparing d4 with a 6 creating a safe
Square for the dark square Bishop rook
to e1 and now Bishop back to a7 talking
the bishop in for later I always like to
mention the knife the g2 doesn't really
pose white any problems you can just
play a rupee too and it's not a problem
white can whenever white plate you know
once I just put the knight back with h3
and it's not gonna be a problem
f5 seems like a like an active move but
your king is still in the center you
haven't cast solder it just seems a very
risky so Bishop back to a 7 by 11 and
now push it back to b3 with castles h3
not allowing Bishop g4 rook to e8 and
now Knight B to d2 with Bishop to e6
challenging White's light-square bishop
and now there are there have been some
games that have reached this position
ambush up the c2 is a known move here
Knight the c4 is a known move Knight to
h2 is a known move Knights the f1 is a
known move but the move nipple plays is
a new move in the position and it is as
of move 11 that we have a completely new
game nepalese push up to a 4 now it
really it really is a weird move hard to
understand what kind of a move is it and
and what it actually does as xi can just
play b5 here and put the bishop back and
this is exactly what level does he plays
b5 and now we have better
see - so what's the idea behind Bishop
a4 I have no idea as black wants to play
b5 at some point so it seems like white
just improved
maybe just give like a temple or it's
some really sort of a really
sophisticated idea that is beyond my
comprehension so if anyone has an idea
on what what Bishop a4 is supposed to do
feel free to you know add add in the
comment section but ok with h6 now
nicely f1 Reema nuvaring the night and
now d5 as white now allowed it you
always want to play d5 when you can with
a capture Sun d5 bushel captures on d5
and now Knight to g3
we have nice the h7 the idea is nice to
f8 the g6 and from there you will be
nicely controlling f4 and h4 with a far
a for now this could be one way you
could look at it why why white wanted to
provoke b5 but the black was gonna play
b5 either way so still not sure about
what the bishop day for idea was about a
bouquet night a fate 11 continues with
his plan will be for now continuing the
expansion on the Queen side and Knight
to g6 with Bishop to e3 now challenging
blacks dark square Bishop Bishop
captures F captures and now Queen to d7
so putting a lot of pressure on on
White's King side for example if the
Queen moves somewhere you can you can
let's say capture here and after G
characters capture the h3 pawn so you
have to be a little bit careful with
Knight back to d2 and now Knight C to e
7 with Knight to b3 this Knight now
wants to come over to c5 as it will be
an excellent outpost Queen to c6 putting
pressure on the g2 pawn and now Queen to
d2 just defending it 11 goes nice to h4
now with a triple attack against the g2
pawn and here with E 4 just blocking the
bishops attack rook to e2
would be would be dangerous because here
black can just capture the point you
haven't really defended it because after
Bishop captures and rook captures you
don't capture the rule
but a night of three check you just pick
up the Queen so after I did four with E
for blocking the bishops attack towards
the G to pawn and now well you could
capture and give up the bishop this way
xi decided to do it in a much more
interesting way Queen to G saying okay
if you capture here I just capture on g3
nepo says no thank you king - H - you're
welcome to have your light square bishop
as it's not doing all that much at the
moment so mushroom back to c6 and now
comes Knight to c5 grabbing this very
nice outpost and although it is a very
nice outpost the knight doesn't really
have all that many squares the knight
can go to but if black ever wants to
push at five and black doesn't want to
push at five and then you will have for
example the e6 square maybe maybe this
Bishop can come to b3 control e6 maybe
the knight can go there and also it kind
of prevents this rook from being
activated as Knight captures any an a6
is a threat where white would just get a
passed pawn so Ireland says ok no
problem we have f5 e captures on f5
night he captures on f5 and now not
trading Queen Jefferson g3 is a threat
Knight to e4 and now this is an
excellent defensive setup with the two
knights this Knight nicely controls the
g3 square if for example you captured
the other night takes this nice place so
it's just an excellent setup with Bishop
to b5 now not allowing Bishop to b3 and
here we have rook to eat - just putting
more well more defense to the Jie du
Pont and while the rook is there the
Queen can now again be activated with
rook a to d8 offering the a6 pawn but
you have to activate the rook somehow
but nipple just ignores it he says no
problem that point is not going anywhere
rook 8 F 1 with Knight to d6 now
preparing some trades on the e4 square
and here comes Queen to e1
there was a there was an interesting
idea d4 just opening up a discovery here
against the Queen and then after some
trades and night
tres nightcap sorry night captures
Bishop captures and rook captures now
you still have this tension going on but
Knight rook captures Knight is a threat
here and now after Queen g5 defending
the knight offering a queen trade now
you play Queen e2 where black cannot
capture because you capture on e8 and
white just has a very nice
well White has an overwhelming position
here so this was one way to go about it
nappa finds a different way it also
includes the same idea the knight on h4
is undefended which is something you
should always look in your own games if
you see if you see a piece in your
opponent's camp that's undefended try to
use this as a motive for for any future
combinations a game that comes to mind
is Gorgon it's a versus tile where tall
used the undefended rocker I believe it
was on e 1 to create a just a
monstrosity of an attack if you haven't
seen that game I will put a link to it
in the description below
it's an old game you know when oh of
course they are all game but it's an old
video back from when my videos were
still at only 30 frames per second but
it's still a very nice game so if you
want to check it out it will be the
first link in the description below but
ok Queen to e1 going after the night
here and now comes night back to f5 and
here well you can capture on a6 nipple
still waits first a 5 you have almost
faded a passport you just have to
capture on a6 and then you will have
created a passed pawn rook the f8
preparing to double up rooks and the F
file and now rook F rook ETF to Nico
doubles up on the F file with rook to f7
preparing to double up on the F file and
now rook to f3 with h5 preparing h4 to
gain more control of the g3 square and
now comes Knight captures on a6 finally
grabbing that pawn and now well whatever
happens happens but Nippo does have a
passed pawn on f5 with h4 by Levin
Knight back to c5 and here comes rook
d2f a doubling up on the F file and here
with King to g1 not not wanting to keep
the King there so if you know
all the pieces clear maybe the g3 square
shouldn't be so available we have Queen
to h6 and now comes Queen to c1 if you
start pushing right away for example
with a six then night the e3 can be sort
of problematic you will have to capture
on f7 but there are tricks involved for
example if Queen captures you just
capture and after rook captures rook
captures an f1 with to check King h2 now
locate one you prevent the pawn from
going any further and also you are
threatening rook f1 which one made ideas
like that
so with Queen to c1 nepo now offers the
Queen trade he would very much enjoy a
queen trait as then he can start pushing
his passport to victory but 11 tries in
the night III just the same so you can't
capture the night it's the same idea
that we've shown oh you have to play
rook captures on f7 we have rook
captures rook captures King captures and
now Queen back to e one you could also
play Bishop to b3 seems like a nice idea
where you can just trade off a lot of
pieces and after Bishop captures and
Knight captures then start pushing your
pawn black it doesn't really have any
threats on the on the Kings side but
okay Queen back the e1 first and only
now Knight captures and c2 with Queen to
have to check King to e8 and now Queen
captures unci do Bishop captures on e4
with Knight captures on e4 Knight
captures deep characters and Quinta III
check King to f1 and now we have Queen
to f4 check King to d7 with the idea of
bringing the King closer to helping out
with with stopping the pass pawn who
seems to have been a better move but 11
goes for Queen to f2 check and already
here Lenny 11 was very low on time
Queen to have two blocking check and now
if you capture then even though you are
in time to stop the past pawn it doesn't
really matter your down upon and while
black is pretty much blacking the stock
guarding the pass tape when you're just
gonna win all the pawns here well you
don't even have to win all of them you
can win as many as you'd like and then
Joe
push your own passports and win the game
on the other hand if you decide to
capture on e4 it's not gonna help you
just king g1 and next you're gonna start
pushing your pawn queen to c6 you have
to prevent the pushing of the pawn but
then Queen captures on h4 you can to
defend everything Queen captures in c3
you're gonna get the king to h2 and then
after King to the seventh a six and
while black is busy dealing with the a6
bun you're just gonna gobble up all the
other points for example Queen c6 you're
gonna play queen g4 check King d8 you're
gonna play a seven and after Queen -
eight and now you'll go after the points
Queen captures here Queen captures now
you're gonna deliver check King these
seven Queen captures I need five and now
you have a very nice control of the c5
square and you can just start pushing
for example the H pawn and that's enough
for a victory so after Queen to have to
you don't trade and you don't capture
here between the c1 check by eleven
Quinta you want and now Queen back to f4
check King the g1 now the Queen also
guards d4 pawn while still pressuring
the h4 pawn king to d8 and now Queen to
F do again offering a trade asking you
maybe wanna capture on e4 now we have
Queen to c1 check still avoiding it and
now came to h2 we have Queen captures on
c3 and now a six kinked a King back to
yet and we have Queen captures on h4
Queen to a3 going after the ace exponent
but now Queen h5 check King to f8 and
here you are more than welcome to pause
the video and try to find the absolute
best winning move for white while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
you know trader of Queens and go over
into winning positions and for those who
just wanna enjoy a show Queen to f3
check you force the Queen trade and then
it's all over
Queen captures on f3 can be played and
after G captures on f3 is just all over
but it was at Queen f3 check that eleven
resigned the game or or here
ran out of time it's one of those I I
know he had I think less than a second
when the time was stopped but I there
this is reasonable so it's just the same
because after Queen captures and pawn
captures just a seven and eight wins the
game so a very nice game and before I
forget let's check out the standings and
like I said it's you know for a quiet
game that's that's a very loud one there
we have it with four and a half points
Fabiana Caruana
ding Liron yani pony she which one at an
island and Sergei kurakin after winning
against Maxie Marshall across the game
we've shown in the previous video then
with four points magnus carlsen still
without a loss but also without a win
all draws same with Wesley stall or all
games drawn and the same with Sharma
media of all eight games drawn then we
have three and a half points onigiri
maxime beaugeois graphic or Nakamura and
the only player which do loss is 11
onion with three points so there we have
it that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank James Norwood
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it and as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the singled
Cup continuing the capablanca saga and
of course checking up on your
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day